oh the marshall
girl marshall well he doesn't get to
play the marshall basically ever but
yeah the yeah i call this position the
marshall now i think no one goes c3 t5
so
any of eight a4 h3
yep i think it's the marshmallow
technically whatever you want to call it
the anti-martial but
c3 d5 doesn't happen so
yeah after a4 he played rook b8
was it twice against
against nepal machine yeah there were
games three and five right and duda he
started using this with black no he lost
the game in the world rapid
against nepalese
and
or maybe he played bishop b7 there i
can't quite recall but dude i recently
started playing
this territory with black himself so
we'll see so like d5 and then maybe he
immediately
took took and then started yeah
anyway this time around he doesn't go
for pawn to d5 but he goes for pawn to
h6 which is the plan you can always play
now if you're if you don't know what to
do in these positions you can always go
h6 for k8 bishop f8 and then have a look
around it's normally not too bad the
duda carlson bishop e3 has been played
here the typical player is rookie h we
should have eight
somewhere let's see how this develops
magnus in the meantime plays the
standard plan h6 rook e8 bishop f8
which yeah as mentioned if you don't
know what to do in these positions it's
barely ever very wrong to go h6 from k8
bishop f8
and then next step is either bishop to
e6 exchanging these bishops or knight e7
and knight g6 in rare exceptions pawn to
d5 could also be one of the options
but generally yeah that's the plan
magnus likes he's played it quite a bit
in the match in different situations
even in the italian he played a very
similar plan there was no bishop on f8
but there's h6 rookie bishop v6
recapturing with the rook
and yeah it served him well no they're
just when oh they went all out for
trying not to let me talk about any of
the course material at all
since this is the one move that the
course does not cover
even for three seconds
and segments says e4 should be called
the int
all right let's uh how do we get
get out of australia
duda
did not play g4 play queen c2 which i'm
sure is a fine move but this might have
been the moment because now magnus goes
with v6
and
he will slowly but surely so
yeah it doesn't really look all that bad
anymore i mean it never really looked
bad but
once white starts making those little
non-moves like quincy two
you you feel that
the advantage is going to
diminish with every decision maybe the
way to try to justify it would be to
take 186 and play d3 d4
and this also you know
kind of justifies playing quincy too
because we've protected the pawn on e4
but often d65 just makes a draw in these
types of positions which is a bit
unfortunate
if
i think night before just wins the pawn
there so
i would play cd4 but i don't think i can
but this one yeah knight g5 force you to
take i take with with a pawn and i'm
of claiming i'm slightly better maybe
could be
t5 e5 f4 this still yeah or c5 g5 and
the bishop on f8 is not not that
beautiful
even though so much got traded off that
maybe it's not that bad but d4 d5 might
just be immediate the quality it often
is in these types of positions
you have to calculate e5 though yeah
that's that's the one i'm unsure about
because we don't have knight takes e4
seems like and if we take on five fights
we'll take take play bishop
d4 f4 maybe even f4 actually yeah maybe
just go ahead options here this i'm not
so sure about this looks scary yeah
if it goes f4 do you take on e4 now i
mean it's definitely yes you do but i'm
not thrilled about it like
i see 4c6 and just claim that the pawn
on the 4 is so horrible that it's not
that bad yeah maybe you hold
well also bishop d4 followed by e5 yeah
i'm a bit worried
yeah definitely it's just kind of
awkward on d4 because it will get
challenged to challenge by c5 very
quickly
but that's like the one way what's what
you want yeah i wanted to go d5 c4
otherwise i think it makes whatsoever
yeah
i still feel like ed is the move somehow
knight takes okay we have to take
cd
no
it's nothing good
the choice has to be between d5 and c5
here right if you if you allow me to
play g4 and d5 those are like i remember
some car pro
caspar of carpool positions
like that which didn't go well for
anatoly in the matches
like in in the sight serves and things
let's see if magnus
goes for one of the lines we debated
yeah yeah it does look like a a very
interesting and maybe crucial option
here
and we need to do something if we play
yeah c5 d5 we should be working this is
what i don't really like yeah this one
it feels like we're a temple short term
yeah this one legit looks very scary 97
f4 knight f3 f5 here just doesn't look
right at all or do you see where with dc
even dc yeah even the c
so yeah well very interesting what
magnus comes up with
and yeah we are we're still actually
doing quite well on the prediction front
queen eight played in the magnus game at
least we had this position
yeah yeah
and we were we were playing with here
but i guess he just takes and goes f3
then
i have a feeling that's the that's the
solution
you're not forced to go r2 but it does
feel kind of logical because otherwise
if you allow rook c4 your position
starts looking kind of suspect
fun fact since you hacked my computer i
can no longer move the pieces i can only
draw arrows now
really
yup
that's a nifty trick
amazing chess analysts
yes
yeah optically it looks like he just
blundered the piece young shishter but
he clearly hasn't because neither four
there's a number of ways not to lose the
d4 bishop
i guess he wants queen c4
but i'm still a bit confused as to why
he played queen d3 there
surely there must have been some other
options like
oh is this is white actually better here
or a little bit but
not not but yeah g6 f5 should be a draw
right but looks like magnus didn't fully
equalize with this genius operation oh
very close yeah we left it after rook a4
b2 and uh
uh young christopher just two can play
bishop d4 which is a clever move using
the fact that 95 loses to rook a1 i
suppose yeah unbeating the rook and then
the knight gets lost
i think we can actually take right
somewhat shockingly
either one
c4
weirdly i don't think we'll lose any
material here we look like we deserve oh
i mean he's just gonna take and take on
d5 yeah that's that's the point here
he's not going after the bishop he's
going after the ball and d5
fair enough
yeah five is a smart move then yeah
black definitely would like to break up
the the pawn chain and this is why i was
kind of surprised at the choice of queen
d3 because
i'd be very much in favor of not
allowing any of these any of these
breaks but maybe
he didn't have a comfortable
alternative
right
yeah i think magnus will be fine
i i don't know if he can improve the
position enough to become better but
so magnus slightly worse but
not not in any serious amounts of
trouble yeah magnus basically like once
you play c7 c6 you know you're safe so
it looks like a queen exchanges yeah
expecting expectations
i don't think this this game is
too long for this world um
the dupe of game is still going along
one of their